der krieg in der ukraine hat viele
gesichter so viele menschen sind
betroffen und auch solche die nicht
direkt vor ort sind sowie schlagerstar
emilia wellbrock ihre stimme begeistert
millionen du bringst den sommer in mein
herz heißt eines ihrer fröhlichen lieder
aber im herzen der ukrainischen
künstlerin ist im moment nur noch trauer
ihr vater michael es den putins krieg
gefallen er war ist 51 jahre alt bevor
wir mit emilia gleich sprechen werden
bleibt chefin nina kirsch bei mir im
studio stellen wir uns wieder welch doch
noch mal kurz vor yamaha ist eigentlich
eine sängerin die für gute laune steht
also wenn man ihre musik hört dann geht
an so ein bisschen das herz auf dann
bekommt man gute laune und hat wirklich
einen guten start in der schlagerszene
hingelegt ihre wurzeln liegen aber in
der ukraine sie ist dort geboren sie ist
dann mit acht jahren nach deutschland
gekommen zusammen mit ihrer mutter und
mit ihrem stiefvater sie hat auch noch
eine schwester und ihr vater ist in der
ukraine geblieben hat zuletzt im dom
bass gelebt dort wo ja schon seit jahren
wirst schon seit jahren gefechte gibt wo
gefechte ja auch den alltag der menschen
bestimmen und tragischerweise ist er
jetzt genau dort vor 56 tagen ums leben
gekommen und im videoblog ist uns jetzt
zugeschaltet wir sprechen jetzt mit ihr
guten namen frau war rock
abend
haben sie überhaupt
informationen über die genauen umstände
des todes ihres vaters bekommen
wir haben nur das bekommen was wir
gehört haben also vor allem haben wir
sehr spät über den tod ab fahren weil es
wurde uns vorenthalten dass er gefallen
ist sind an der front und wir haben nur
dann das schreiben bekommen wie er ums
leben gekommen ist walter irgendwie ein
geschoss in seiner nähe direkt
explodiert ist und dadurch ist er
gestorben
vw rock ist ihr vater eigentlich
freiwillig in den krieg gezogen oder
musste erkämpfen wie ist das abgelaufen
es ist ein sehr kompliziertes thema weil
er hat er das nicht als krieg ist sehr
kompliziert vom thematik weil er das
nicht verstanden hat dass das krieg ist
ihm wurde erzählt dass es sein training
falls es aufstände gibt in der stadt wo
er lebt und das hieß entweder sie müssen
oder ihr sohn als sollte gesagt ja ich
gehe weil es wird eh nichts passieren
weil das training und dass das bald
vorbei das hat er mir versichert am
telefon wir haben acht tage vorher
miteinander gesprochen und er meinte
keine sorge wir werden uns sehen und
alles wird gut werden
und er ist halt auch gegangen weil er
dachte wenn was sein sollte dann
beschützt er halt gleichzeitig unseren
bruder wir haben ein halbbruder
aber ihm war das nicht klar dass das so
sein wird und dass er im krieg weil er
hat gesagt ich bin kein soldat
eigentlich darf ich auch nicht auf weil
es ein konflikt ist weil er in
dieser umgebung wohnte uns nicht
wirklich ein
pass hatte das heißt ja wurde von der
größten eingezogen und sie haben den
ausgeliefert und es wurden ganz viele in
der region leute die ukrainer sind und
es hieß nur training und die banale
eingezogen und an die front geschickt
und die wussten gar nicht was passiert
als sie damals dieses telefonat mit ihm
geführt haben war ihnen natürlich nicht
klar dass das das letzte gespräch mit
ihrem kleiner sein würde was bleibt
ihnen jetzt im nachhinein davon ganz
besonders in erinnerung
gerufen
tatsächlich als er mir ja auch das
aufgenommen gehabt das gespräch bleibt
mir wie er sagt
ich würde gern noch etwas leben und uns
sehen weil wir haben uns jahrelang nicht
gesehen und wir haben lang von geträumt
es endlich zu sehen und dass er das
gesagt hat dass er es kaum erwarten kann
mich zu sehen und meine schwester
war rock es gibt immer wieder falsche
nachrichten menschen auch aus russland
die immer noch nicht verstehen was da
eigentlich passiert genau so wie er sie
ja auch gerade sagten dass ihr vater
nicht richtig wusste was da eigentlich
los ist
hat er ihnen im vorfeld oder noch
irgendwie erzählen können wie genau die
situation vor ort war
war da viel beschluss hatte er angst wie
er ging es ihm in den letzten tagen
bevor er dann tatsächlich in den krieg
musste ja unwissentlich
erb ja dass man und dann alles ruhig ist
und eigentlich in der stadt wo er wann
nichts passiert und das ist eigentlich
nur weil er sein konflikt war dass er in
so einem stadion vom leben war dass er
es ihm egal was recht und unrecht hat er
wollte nur dass es vorbei ist das ja ein
ausweis bekommt mit dem man einfach
reisen kann und er kann weil sein
größter traum war einfach weg zu kommen
von dort wo er ist weil es sehr
schwierig war und mein bruder zum
beispiel erzählte dass da überhaupt
keine gefahr weil selbst mein bruder
wurde es gab es in der schule ist und
dass man sich entscheiden kann welche
hauptsprache seine sprache seine tops
russisches oder ukrainisch aber da gab
es auch schon so viel propaganda dass
mein vater selbst oftmals glaubte um ein
gold bald wird uns die russische sprache
ich ihm verboten wird das verboten und
deswegen war das leben da ihr schwierig
und auch alles was er gesagt hat er hat
nie was gegen die ukraine gesagt manche
kämpfe nicht gegen die ukraine dann ging
die leute die uns hier töten wollen weil
er sich mehr als russen weil seine
mutter russin war er war halb ukraine
halb große
ganze konflikte wenn es jetzt geht also
in dieser eine person in ihrem vater
gespiegelt ich schätze mal dass sie
aufgrund der besonderen situation unter
gefahr dort an seiner beerdigung nicht
teilnehmen konnten
nein das konnte ich nicht kommt noch
nicht mal die ehre immer weisen mich zu
verabschieden
[Musik]
aber mein halbbruder hat mir die
möglichkeit gegeben eine voice messages
zu machen und er hat das dann abgespielt
meine worte und dafür bin ich ihnen
dankbar dass ich wenigstens die chance
hatte dass ich wenigstens nicht so
verabschieden konnte
hier ist es dann mit ihrem halbbruder
haben sie mal überlegt ihn nach
deutschland zu holen hat er die
wirklichkeit nach deutschland zu kommen
oder möchte er das womöglich gar nicht
hat die möglichkeit nicht aber er meinte
wenn ich könnte würde er so weit weg
seine worte war ich möchte so weit weg
ist geht von russland das waren seine
worte meinte am liebsten würde er nach
japan oder irgendwohin er würde auch
gern nach deutschland
er meinte aber er hat kein
personalausweis er gehört weder zu
russland noch zu ukraine zu nichts und
er meinte ich könnte an die front gehen
mich ergeben und sagst du ich weiß die
ukraine würden wir nichts tun weil die
halten sich an die an die regeln die
gesetze weil saxo die ukraine deren
traum ist es frei zu bleiben und dass
sie einfach vielleicht ein teil von
europa werden deswegen würden sie
niemals regen uns irgendwelche bestimmte
gesetze brechen er sagte aber was
passiert dass die russen miteinander
schießen weil ich bin ich gehöre ein
paar kein und keiner so keiner wird
erbarmen haben egal was ich tue ich das
einzige was er machen kann ist sich in
seiner zu hause verstecken und das war
es und er kann auch niemandem trauen
weil selbst weil er studiert kann ich
ihnen jeweils selbst in der uni die
leute die wegschicken in den krieg und
sagen was machst du jede musst du musst
an die front
wer ob sie singen eigentlich fröhliche
schlager lieder jetzt sind sie plötzlich
drin mittendrin in diesem krieg in
diesem konflikt in all diesen mir leid
und all diesem elend wird sie das
verändern
ja es hat nicht schon verändern muss ich
sagen
und weil es einfach schwierig ist so
wissen dass einfach jemand überleben
andere bestimmt und eine so
ungerechtigkeit auf der welt ist egal
welcher krieg es ist
das einfach ein leben so genommen werden
kann und möglichkeiten träume hoffnungen
sehnsüchte und du bleibst einfach zurück
mit 10.000 tragen
und aber irgendjemand das beschlossen
hat wie dein leben weiter verlaufen wird
ob du willst oder nicht und dass die
milliarden von menschen auf der welt so
viele kriege gibt und das leiden immer
die in die nichts dafür können und ich
finde es ganz schlimm dass es leute gibt
die sagen na ja also ist es im krieg das
sterben mensch und ich sagte ja aber so
sollte es sein wo wir sind im 21
jahrhundert also was ist denn los mit
uns warum empfinden wir als massenmord
etwas was not abnormales im krieg warum
ist überhaupt krieg in diesem
jahrhundert noch möglich warum sind
nicht schlauer aber wir stellen uns hin
dass irgendwer mit die intelligentesten
wesen auf bekannten ertappter 240 daran
muss ich sagen
frau berg ganz herzlichen dank für
dieses gespräch danke dass sie mit uns
gesprochen er gerne und vor allem alles
danke schön hier an arbeit und dann an
das bett teilen 7 vielen dank wen kraft
viel kraft danke danke schön